because anthony davis no surprise is
going to remain in the lakers uniform so
today's uh little bit of news uh shams
from the athletic davis opted out of his
28.7 million dollar player option
re-signing with the lakers
uh the reason this is just an excuse for
me to bring up anthony davis because
actually we spent the whole weekend
rightfully so
uh
praising the king
you know and talking about lebron james
and we've mentioned anthony davis but i
don't know if we've devoted a
concentrated conversation to anthony
davis and we and we've joked about it
along the way in the in the you know
early history of the show what does it
show 24 or something like that
yeah because off camera and we were in
i mean you can't really call the
rehearsal mode we had like half a run
but when we talked we were talking on
the phone we were talking about like we
always do
yeah
and
you know you said
that you called anthony davis a loser
and you've taken it back and you you've
since walked it back but i'm i'm not
bringing i'm not bringing that up to rub
your face in the fact you call that
no that's actually not what i'm doing
that's actually not what i'm doing okay
context man i'm bringing it up
because i'm posing the question to you
if i were talking to somebody who had
not called anthony davis a loser i
wouldn't ask i wouldn't say that i
wouldn't say you know michael holly
called anything no i'm talking to you
this is how you saw him
going into this postseason yes
i'm just wondering how you view him now
now that he's got a championship and he
didn't just get it
he was right there riding shotgun with
lebron and plenty of times he took the
wheel in this series
how do you view anthony davis
now he's a hall of famer if you ask me
now
he walks away from the game he's a hall
of famer he's probably already a hall of
famer without the championship now he
cemented it and there's still work to be
done so how do you see him now and how
where can he take this thing moving
forward given we've already seen him at
age 27.
it's a it's a great question you know
there's something i'm going to take a
little bit of what thomas dimitrov said
and apply it actually to this answer
believe it or not
you know when he said and i thought was
very insightful great interview by the
way with thomas
i think one of the things he said that
that really spoke to me is that
how you are you begin in this business
his business and it really applies to a
lot of us
you begin as a grinder
and you're just trying to make your way
you're trying to stay afloat you're
trying to show that you belong but
nobody ever talks to you about
leadership and you
you learn that as you start doing it
and so
as i have
traveled in my career
and gone through different experiences
in my career i understand more and this
is michael really in the last three or
four years
i understand
the culture of an organization and being
in a good situation
more than ever that's why there's no
excuse for me calling anthony davis a
loser about a month and a half ago
because i know better
just about being in a bad situation i
didn't want to accept
that there was something beyond what i
saw on the court with the new orleans
pelicans and so i think
my flaw my flaw
up until three or four years ago is just
focus on the field on the court on the
diamond and saying that's it but it's a
much more global thing than that anthony
davis got himself out of a bad situation
i don't like the way he did it in it
he handled it yeah
yeah but what he was saying was that i
got it okay i've been here for seven
years this is not working let me get out
of here so i look at him
as a very good player as a as an elite
player amazing he really is he's an
amazing player he got himself to a good
situation and i don't know if you
remember this the other day when i said
uh we didn't really
uh elaborate on elaborate much on it
when i said it's generational we were
talking about that whole that inevitable
lebron
versus uh jordan thing
when i said jordan couldn't have done it
what i should have said is jordan
wouldn't have
he wouldn't have done it because that
generationally that was that wasn't a
paradigm that was yeah that's not the
paradigm
so people say hey if michael jordan
teamed up with yes
yeah yeah if he had teamed up with magic
they could have won
they neither one of them could have done
it because they were still rightly or
wrongly i think it's incorrect but
rightly or wrongly they were still
thinking this is
my team i'm going to carry my team and
players today
whether they be lebron james
or anthony davis or kevin durant
don't think like that they don't well
it's so weird it's the idea of like
go ahead i'm sorry
no no i was gonna say like we we kind of
get away from
applying 1980s and early 1990s
lenses
to what they're doing in the 21st
century it's just a different
it's just a difference yeah but but even
then we kind of still do it because
you're right i mean there were plenty of
people who who had a problem with how
anthony davis conducted himself on the
way out in new orleans like the phrase
means to an end
comes to mind for me because i think
about how
you know it's just it's this it's this
rings mentality this championship
mentality
uh that
we're probably as if not more obsessed
with than the players who actually
compete for said championships and
here's what i mean by man because that's
because even kevin durant i don't know
when it was because you know sometimes
they'll say something months ago but
then it'll pop up on your timeline the
kevin durant was on a podcast i think it
might have been jj reddick's podcast he
was talking about how he earned his
rings
in golden state um
and he's since golden state he still has
people going at him about leaving
oklahoma city to join golden state which
was the most extreme example
of this this these new dudes
how these new dudes do business you know
what i mean um
but really what it comes down to man is
it's like you're damned if you do damn
if you don't because if you're anthony
davis and he it and i actually like that
you called him a loser because it helps
us to illustrate what we're talking
about if you're anthony davis and
whether it was injuries poor supporting
cast poor management whatever it was
the western conference
whatever or maybe his own shortcomings
whatever the reason was where you only
got to the only got to the playoffs a
few times in what seven years
and you go your career because you want
to stick it out and you don't win a
championship then you're like oh you
never won a championship and you're
defined for what you never did he never
won a championship and i love damien
lillard i love damien lillard but if
damian littleton and cj mccollum keep
that attitude and retire with a
championship are we gonna give them a
retire without a championship excuse me
they keep the attitude that no we're not
gonna be like the rest of these cats
we're gonna do it in portland and we're
gonna see it through when they retire
ringless are we going to give them props
be like yo he was awesome and it doesn't
matter he never won a championship he
did it the old-fashioned way it is the
hard way hell no we we know people and
we look at people through the prism of
how many championships they have so and
you know who was saying that have done
it
who would
you know who will give them those props
people in portland barkley that's about
it oh people are people in portland yeah
or people
heads
but
you're right you're right man but it's
like but just like so anthony davis
changed the narrative around him
by getting to la and not just getting
there and he didn't just ride lebron's
coattails like i said he was riding a
shotgun with the best player in the
world was the best player on the team uh
at various stages of the postseason run
uh you know showed out in the finals
very soon will be the best player on the
team and what i'm gonna and listen
you're talking about a 27 year old who's
already a four-time first-team all-nba
guy already a two-time first team all
all-defense already a three-time block
champion i don't know how in the numbers
you are in general and i don't know how
into player efficiency rating you are in
particular not a perfect stat but a
pretty telling one so as you may know
the all-time leader in player efficiency
is michael jordan at 27.9
lebron's number two at 27.49
career player efficiency number three is
anthony davis
anthony davis
at 27 27.42
so i'm saying like where he is right now
what he has left to work with with
lebron forever many more years lebron
wants to play
anthony davis
is not only going to be a fixture or
continue to be a fixture for first team
all-nba
but he has an opportunity now because of
that power move
to move up the rankings and to move up
and for people to truly appreciate he's
always been great always been great and
now he starts adding some there you go
rings to his resume
we're going to start having to have a
conversation about anthony davis
among the all-time greats very very
michael
mike if we're not already this all i
have to say
because i need a drink of water
so i'm gonna take a little break but all
i'm gonna say is
uh he's a fixture
he's moving up the rankings
and he's a winner that's my dude anthony
james
that's my guy a winner
i love him
you